we're on problem 201 which I had
continued in the last video but frankly
I had bad reading comprehension I had
read the first statement right I went
down a kind of incorrect path so let me
read it correctly if the sum of n
consecutive integers is zero which of
the following must be true so have n
numbers in the row and their sum has to
be 0 so first of all that tells us that
some of them have to be positive and
some of them have to be negative and
they're consecutive right so if we put
this as 0 I mean let's think about how
we can even construct this how this
could ever happen and consecutive
numbers the sum being 0 well if we have
I mean it really in order to do that for
and they're consecutive which is you
know a trick if I mean if a is one of
the numbers if a is one of the numbers
then really negative a has to be one of
the numbers as well and why is that you
might say oh well you know why can't I
have some other set of negative numbers
that offset a well the key here is that
we're dealing with consecutive numbers
because those other negative numbers
we're going to have to offset all of the
other positive numbers in between and
maybe I should do this with with more
abstract so let's say that n is equal to
1 right and and the sum of n consecutive
integers is 0 because so first of all
can n equal 1 well sure only if that one
integer is 0 right now what if n is
equal to 2
can any quill - well let's think about
it we have to add one integer to this
and there they're integers right so if
we add one integer if we had any
positive integer here a then the sum is
going to be 0 plus a I mean if you're
going across the negative boundary if
you're going to cross 0 zero has to be
one of your integers right so that's
always going to be counted so in order
to get to negative a you need to have at
least three integers right so if I said
that n is equal to 3 sure you could do 1
0 and minus 1 now if n is equal to 4 can
I just add
numbered on either Kannada either a 2 or
negative 2 no that'll change the sum
again so I have to add a 2 and a minus 2
so I think you can see here that there's
a pattern because 0 is always going to
be one of the integers and it's
symmetric on the right on the left hand
side we're always going to have an odd
number of numbers of integers we're
summing up so we know that n is odd and
is odd and this was so we know statement
1 they say statement 1 and even that's
not true we actually can't construct it
with n is even statement 2 says n is odd
which we've just shown and then
statement 3 is the average of the n
integers is 0 well sure I mean you know
what's the average it's the sum it's the
sum of the integers divided by n right
well they're telling us that the sum of
the integers is 0 so 0 divided by
anything as long as we don't have 0
integers is 0 so 2 & 3 are both correct
so the choice is e next question 202 202
excuse me in the formula V is equal to 1
over 2 R cubed if R is halved then V is
multiplied by what the easiest thing I
always find a do to this is take numbers
so let's say if R is 2 what happens and
then let's have it when R equals 1 and
see what happens to be I mean we could
do it analytically but this is what this
is frankly the easiest way to do it so
you could say when R is equal to 2 V is
equal to 1 over 2 times 2 is 4 to the
third power 64 and then when R is 1 you
get 1 over C 2 times 1 is 2 to the third
power so you get 1/8 so what happened to
V we essentially multiplied it by 8
right
so that is right that is choice B to go
from one sixty four to one eight you
have to multiply by eight you could view
one-eighth as the same thing as eight
sixty fourths that clarifies it at all I
always find it easier to deal with
actual physical numbers where they say
oh if you change this variable by a
factor of five what happens to that
variable so easy to just well anyway it
could get very confusing if you actually
try to do an r1 and an r2 and r1 is two
times r2 and all of that
next question 203 a certain bakery has
six employees
it pays annual salaries of fourteen
thousand to each of two employees so to
make 14k sixteen thousand to one
employee so one employee makes 16 K and
17 thousand to each of the remaining
three employees fair enough the average
annual salary of these employees is
closest to which of the following so we
have to take the sum of all of their
salaries and divide by six so it'll be
two times fourteen plus 1 times 16 which
is 16 plus 3 times 17 3 times 17 and we
divide it by 6 2 times 14 is 28 plus 16
plus 51 all of that over 6 and let's see
what is that equal to 28
16:51 8 plus 6 is 14 14 plus 1 is 15 1
plus 2 is 3 3 plus 1 is 4 4 plus 5 is 9
right and this was 8 plus 6 95 divided
by 6
sorry 95 divided by 6 I think my brain
was computing ahead of me because 96
divided by 6 so 96 divided by 6 is equal
to 16 right so this number is just gonna
be just under 16 it's 15 + 5 6 so they
want to get an approximate as closest Oh
actually do they have a lot of numbers
that are really close so let me let me
let me make sure that I I get it right
so not 6 goes into 95
they didn't have numbers that weren't
close I wouldn't do this six goes into
90 609-617 8 times 8 times 6 is 48
remember we were dealing in thousands
when I said you know 16,000 1,000 so you
know now we're at fifteen point eight
thousand so 8 times 48 26 goes into 23
times ok I think that's close enough to
what we need right so it's going to be
roughly fifteen thousand eight hundred
dollars or fifteen point eight thousands
and that is choice C at first I said oh
maybe we can approximate and they had
sixteen thousand ever then I saw the
fifteen eight says oh well we should we
should do a little bit more math you
don't want to get too careless next
problem
204 204 if X is equal to the sum of the
even integers from forty to sixty
inclusive so forty so X is equal to the
sum of even integers from forty to sixty
it is my ad-hoc notation and Y is the
number of even integers and Y is the
number of even in to see if X is equal
to the sum of the even integers from
forty to sixty inclusive so it includes
40 and 60 from forty to sixty it
includes both of them and Y is the
number of even integers from forty to
sixty inclusive what is the value of x
plus y okay so the number Y is an easy
thing how many integers are there
between 40 and 60 if you include both of
them so and this is always a tricky
thing to think about but if you think
about it you know if I said the numbers
1 2 & 3 how many integers are there here
well you clearly you can count them 1 2
& 3 but if you wanted a quick way of
saying you could say ok 3 minus if I
just took the end
- the starting point I would get how
many ended I would get these integers
right so then I'd want to add one so if
I wanted to know how many integers are
there between 60 and 40 I would say 60
minus 40 and that'll give me 41 42 43 44
all the way to 59 and 60 and then I have
to add one because we're including 40 as
well so the y is equal to 21 y is equal
to 21 now let's think about is there a
way is there an easy way to add up all
of the integers between 40 and all of
the even oh no sorry y is the number of
even integers from 40 to 60 so that's
that's not right so the even integers
frankly it might just be easier to let's
just write them out 40 42 44 46 48 50 52
54 56 58 and 60 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
11 integers so that's why and we need to
take the sum of all of these right so
there's a couple of ways we could think
about it you could view this as 40 plus
0 40 plus 240 plus 3 and so forth all
the way to 40 plus 8 and so if you
wanted to add up at least up to this
point there's a pretty straightforward
way of doing it you could just say well
that's 4 there's 1 2 3 4 5 of them so
it's equal to 40 times 5 right that adds
up all the 40's plus 2 plus 4 plus 6
plus 8 so 2 plus 4 is 6 plus 6 is 12
plus 8 is 20 so plus 20 so that's 40
times 5 is what 200 plus 20 is equal to
220 use the same logic here this is 50
plus 0 50 plus 2 all the way to 50 plus
10 and how many are there there's one
two three four five six so it's equal to
six times 56 times 50 plus 2 plus 4 is 6
plus 6 is 12 plus 8 is 20 which we
actually already knew we already
calculated they're 20 because these
don't contribute to the Oh No plus 10
sorry plus 10 don't want to get careless
plus 10 right because this is there are
six of these is plus zero plus 2 plus 4
plus 6 plus 8 plus 10 so it's 20 plus 10
plus 30 right 2 plus 4 plus 6 plus 8
plus 10 is 30 so 6 times 5 is 300 plus
30 is equal to 330
so 330 plus 220 and these numbers have a
strange pattern well there is a formula
or if you want to add the first n
numbers but not you know they change it
a little bit by talking about even
number so I wanted to do it manually so
you go 0 5 & 5 so 550 is the sum and
then we know that y this is X X is equal
to 550 and Y is equal to 11 we figured
that out before so X plus y is equal to
550 plus 11 which is equal to 561 which
is thank goodness actually one of the
choices and that's choice D see you in
the next video